I worked with um one guy who was
quitting and I said Bill if you leave
now you're it's going to haunt you for
the next 20 years he was like 60 and and
and it's going to te up inside for 20
years you're going to be a loser and
you're going to know it and there you
can your way around it but
you're going to know it in your bones
but if you stick it out here for 6 more
months we'll kick ass and you can walk
out of here a winner with your head held
high you'll be a better F grandfather
and husband and um what do you have to
lose what the hell are you running home
for there's nothing there for you you
got to stay here and you know I I had
like 30 seconds to make that pitch but
it stuck it worked Bill Bill actually
stayed for two years but he totally
kicked ass we did a great job saved the
business and um and and he went on a
hero and everybody recognized him for
that and I I think more than anything
that's what people want um deep down
inside they don't want Comfort they they
want they want want to do something
cool
all right guys bang bang I've got Jeff
here uh Jeff you are probably the number
one turnaround artist in the United
States maybe even in the world uh
there's lots of crises that occur uh
some of it's mismanagement and sometimes
people just started a bad business
either a bad Market a bad business model
Etc when you see the crisis how do you
determine whether the business can be
saved or it's just a bad business and it
deserves to die you know um for sure
everybody says oh it's it's external
factors it's the industry it's something
else
um and and really it's you know sort of
manufacturing you try to figure out what
what root caus is try to get to the
basis of that you know if it um if it
really is industrywide I worked with a
computer reseller recently and according
to him the all the manufacturers pulled
back credit a couple years ago you know
so okay if that's true and you're in
trouble what what's if everybody else in
trouble is are you the best performer
did everybody else go out of business
with this set of
circumstances what happened is that was
Universal but then
they everybody hit this Pivot Point like
my credit's gone what do I do they made
a horrible decision and wning got uh
merchant cash advance money and that's
ultimately what's killing them $47
million business and um and there's just
nothing left because the MCAS are
picking picking them alive um the so
it's it's really that you know you talk
to the owners and you just get a sense
uh you know are they really committed
are they goofballs are they are you know
do they have the wrong Focus somewhere
else H those sorts of
things now when you've seen I don't know
hundreds maybe thousands of these crises
at this point I kind of think of it like
you're the firefighter the fire is
blazing someone's called you up and said
hey we come put out the fire what are
the things that you see in the fire that
would cause you to not want to go save
it right or like what of the things that
would turn you off from a situation is
it people are there other things that
are kind of the red flags where you're
like hey even though I'm the best at
what I do I can't save that business or
I don't want to go spend time doing
that um in general there's no set of
circumstances that'll scare me off um
probably my most radical was I got a
call um from a bank the CEO committed
suicide yesterday um there's uh four
felonies being investigated revenues
have fallen from 46 million to 6 million
and about to go to zero and I was in
there next day running the business
um be because as long as I can draw a
clear line of all that fraud and all
those felonies happened previous to me
and you know in that case I reached out
to the um State Attorney General and
just said hey I just arrived if you need
to arrest anybody you know give me a
call I'll have them meet you in the
parking lot uh but we're running a clean
ship here and we're trying to fix the
business so it's not some much
circumstances it's really the people
it's um you know kind of if you if you
think of um alcoholics synonymous or
CrossFit gym um it's the people who come
in and really are ready to change your
life and really are ready to to to go
down A New Path with passion and
commitment if I have somebody who's
bullshitty Dick around with like
oh I think I want to lose weight I'm
tired of being 400 lbs but you know um
you can tell if they're not serious
about why should I be more serious about
fixing their problems than they are um
we once had a guy who was drinking
himself to death locked himself in his
apartment when he should have been at
work was out of options called AA and AA
said we don't go in mug people with
treatment they have to come to us um and
um and and that's kind of me you know
when somebody's ready to change uh in
their heart then you know they're my
best client I'm their best friend but
it's they've got to have have that
commitment and there's a lot of people
who sort of Dilly do around the edges
but aren't aren't ready to take that
that plunge yet so you wrote this book
corporate turnaround Artistry fix any
business in a 100 days and when I read
this I was like I got to talk to Jeff
like this this is a uh Bible it almost
seems like in terms of corporate
turnarounds it's almost 300 Pages or
about 300 pages and my number one lesson
from this was your job is to motivate
people like there's all kinds of tips
tricks you know hacks all these
different things but at the end of the
day got to motivate people to actually
want to uh fix these businesses can you
give me a couple of examples of things
that you've done to actually when you
walk in there's the folks who kind of
messed it up and then there's the people
who are going to stick around what are
the things you've done to motivate
people that you kind of now use as part
of your playbook you know I I would say
if you step back if you gave everybody
in the world the opportunity right now
today you can relive the most heroic
moment of your life or you can sit on
the couch and take it easy um they're
all going to say no no no no I want to
go relive the most heroic moment of my
life and that probably involved a lot of
sweat some pain discomfort fear all
these things that no one really wants
but we do as humans deep down inside
because we know it's it it's worth it in
the end um so I think everybody has that
latent urge to run up you know charge up
the hill and do something awesome um so
for me it's trying to Define that in you
know take a a union Shop full of bunch
of tough old guys who have been working
in a factory that's pretty easy because
I just go in and talk to them like a
high school football coach and um you
know Hey listen this got all screwed up
y'all had a bit a bit of this because
you weren't working hard enough but what
we're going to do is we're going to work
hard we're going to go kick ass and you
really need to motivate them everybody
wants to go kick some ass somewhere and
um and you give them like we're this is
what we're going to do we're going to go
and with a linear Focus people hatch on
to it they love it now I go into you
know you take a pharmaceutical business
and I'm talking about let's do more with
less and they all want to do less with
more um that's just the culture where
everybody's kind of overpaid and taking
it easy that's a lot tougher so you have
to get their attention you know maybe
it's shutting down a division maybe it's
firing their boss uh but there's got to
be some sort of um Thunderclap to get
everybody's attention and then once they
realize they're fighting for survival
some will leave because there's an
easier path but um a lot will stick out
and and and do the heroic battle to
bring this business back reclaim our
pride you know and then you can leave I
I worked with um one guy who was
quitting and I said Bill if you leave
now you're it's going to haunt you for
the next 20 years he was like 60 and and
and it's going to te up inside for 20
years you're going to be a loser and
you're going to know it and there's you
can your way around it but
you're going to know it in your bones
but if you stick it out here for six
more months we'll kick ass and you can
walk out of here a winner with your head
held high you'll be a better F
grandfather and husband and um what do
you have to lose what the hell are you
running home for there's nothing there
for you you got to stay here and you
know I I had like 30 seconds to make
that pitch but it stuck it worked Bill
Bill actually stayed for two years but
he totally kicked ass we did a great job
saved the business and um and and he
went on a hero and everybody recognized
him for that and I I think more than
anything that's what people want um deep
down inside they don't want Comfort they
they want they want want to do something
cool so I remember watching uh years ago
Marcus lonus uh he had a TV show called
The Profit and one of my takeaways from
watching that although There Was You
Know cool stories and cool businesses
and stuff was sometimes he showed up and
they were like oh my God thank you
Marcus for showing up and saving us
other times he showed up and they were
like get the hell out like we want
nothing to do with you
what is the receptivity when you show up
right you're you're known as the
turnaround guy like are they excited to
see you is it a mixed reaction what is
that been like it it's a mixed reaction
um the screw balls definitely don't want
me around the the people who you know
the hard workers who feel oppressed do
and then there's sort of a Middle Road
of people who sort of doing their belly
um one speech I often given you didn't
walk into to this business whatever you
15 years ago go with this shitty work
ethic you don't tell your kids if your
kids knew the shitty work ethic you're
bringing in here every day they'd be
embarrassed for you if your parents knew
they'd probably slap you um and you
didn't walk in here like this the
culture brought you down we're going to
fix the culture and you got to you got
to bring the culture back up and the
culture is going to bring you up and
that's the that's the bulk of the people
and and they like that they again they
want to be part of a winning team and um
and they're willing to you know people
were raised right people have a good
work ethic they know right from wrong
it's just that the culture hasn't
required or demanded that of them in a
long time and um and they're
actually relieved and inspired when when
you do demand that of them because
people people want to perform at their
best that makes complete sense uh we've
talked a little bit about the internal
uh changes that you have to go through
uh another thing that you talk about is
one of the first steps once you get
inside of these businesses is you
immediately call up all the vendors and
aggress L start renegotiating with them
or trying to get some relief from them
uh it's not dissimilar from you know
maybe a private Equity Firm like 3G is
famous for you know being hyper hyper
aggressive with a lot of these vendor
relationships and so what is those
conversations like and what are some of
the tactics that you've used and now you
say Hey whenever I've got to renegotiate
these seem to really work this episode
is brought to you by cal.com what do I
have in common with Chad Hurley from
YouTube Toby from Shopify and Alexis
from 776 and the co-founder of Reddit we
all use cal.com instead of cly and we
are all early investors as well cal.com
is leading the charge of scheduling
Platforms in the open-source sphere
offering you the chance to harness the
efficiency previously reserved for lead
corporations and Tech gurus if you like
to have your calendar organized and be
able to have an efficient exchange when
scheduling but you love all of the
benefits of open- source technology then
cal.com is for you they are transforming
sophisticated calendar management into
an accessible tool for all via a
userfriendly interface you can customize
it and you can make your calendar work
for you use code pomp for $500 off when
you set up your team with cal.com today
again go to cal.com
c.com and use code pomp to get $500 off
when you sign up cal.com an open-source
tool that allows you to take back
control of your calendar be efficient
when scheduling and make sure that no
one can steal your
time and I walk into a tough situation
because generally um payables are all
waged the vendors haven't been paid and
um and and I you know ideally I don't
want to pay them anytime too soon
because I don't have cash and I want
them to give me a lower price which is
probably impossible so what I say is
here's a plan where you're going to keep
shipping us we're going to we're
eventually going to deal with the past
dues but most importantly I want to keep
you as a vendor I could replace you
today but I don't want to I want to keep
you as a vendor but I need cash flow I
need I need additional terms I need you
know this that or the other some kind of
Grace from you once we solve the cash
issue then we're going to go over to the
p&l issue because the company is not
profitable enough then I'm going to
really work you over for pricing and
we're going to make it fair but I want
the sharpest price you have not not the
dullest price you have and then once we
solve the profit issue we're going to go
over and deal with the balance sheet and
that's where your past dues are which
we're freezing for the moment uh and
then we're going to find a Equitable way
to deal with those um worst case we all
know that bankruptcy um provides the
opportunity to work out debts to haircut
or stretch or what have you I don't want
to do that I'm not threatening it but we
all know that's an option so after we
get to solve the cash and then we solve
the profits then we're going to deal
with the debts fairly um and we know
we'll have open conversations and see
what the the company can afford to pay
and and um you know I'm thinking of like
every damn client I have right now they
just can't afford even when we fix the
company they can't afford the balance
sheet because they just have too much
debt um and then it's really a
conversation of I mean I got one right
now um I can give you 20 cents I can I
can pay off 20 cents on the dollar um
over four years or we can just go into
bankruptcy can get 10% over three years
it's it's your choice but you know let's
be friends why not work this out out of
court um keep the lawyers out of it and
get you a higher recovery but
mathematically you know um how can you
show me how I can pay anymore here's our
projections and
um emotionally they'll fight but
eventually the logic part of their brain
takes over and um and they say yeah I I
get it unfortunately um and you usually
have to go through several people in the
organization and get to CFO or president
somebody who can really understand in
their lawyer who says yeah it kind of is
what it is and we you know we need to
accept this does it change or they fight
or they fight like hell and then my
number one mission is to get rid of them
um yeah and you know and go give
somebody else our our profit or go allow
somebody else to make profits on us for
the next 10 years does it change at all
when the vendor is a software vendor
versus maybe somebody that's you know
providing equipment or some other kind
of physical economy type product yes um
only because of the cloud it used to be
you know you buy software and um they'd
say well we're not going to service you
I'm like fine um I'll call you when I
need service you know I don't I don't
give my plumber a monthly retainer why
the hell would I give you one uh but now
they have Cloud access they can just
turn it off so it's it almost has become
like a utility you know like the gas
company we just got to pay a monthly
maybe we won't you know we'll put the
old balances on ice but we've got to pay
monthly um either full or or or partial
but it's yeah software has a lot more
leverage than they used to now one of
the uh quotes uh that I've heard over
and over again that's probably one of my
favorite quotes in business is that
companies die by Suicide not homicide
and it's just them doing constantly
stupid things um in the book one of The
really stupid things that you highlight
is you say Google IRS 941 prison and you
call it the dumbest crime in America
explain what this is and then why do
people fall victim to it um so a 941 is
the as an employer you um you're a
trustee for the withholdings for taxes
from your employees the employment taxes
and whatnot um and and all it does is I
take it from your paycheck and I give it
to the government it's not mine to touch
or take but when company's getting
trouble and CEOs get in trouble they say
well geez there's a bunch of cash why
don't I just use that today we'll pass
it on to the government in a couple
months um the problem is the IRS has
made this the number one um the the
number one law to go after and punish
and when you Google IRS 941 prison
you'll find all these people who got uh
you know um found guilty and are in
prison because they Tred to play the 941
game it's you know my my first question
is what the hell are you accomplishing I
mean if you really have the miracle
solution yeah maybe it makes sense to
take that risk if you really have the
Miracle Solution none of these people
had the Miracle Solution they were just
hoping and dreaming and thinking I'll
rip off my employees in the IRS to fund
my delusional fantasy and eventually you
know the the order fairy will come
around um of course there's records you
know I always say if you're going to rob
a bank go go in with a ski mask because
they don't know who you are when you're
doing like white collar Bank crime they
they know where the money went to they
have the accounts they have the records
they have the Ein n numbers like there's
no possible way you can outsmart that
kind of crime um but people do it it's
impulsive um and it's boy the IRS just
hammers on folks so when I come in and
find that we have to um quickly deal
with the IRS make it known come up with
a payment plan and um and you know stay
away from their their sharp knives so
you mentioned delusion and one of the
things immedately jump to is there seems
like uh there's a growing number of
entrepreneurs who don't have uh what I
would consider kind of just basic
Financial skills or understanding read a
p&l read a balance sheet understand how
some of this works uh and it feels like
maybe those two things are related like
you get increased delusion the less that
you are uh well-versed in kind of core
you know accounting or or financial
metrics uh is that true in your
experience where you know people just if
you don't understand the numbers then
dreams run wild and it leads you to ruin
yeah yeah largely um interestingly
people who really understand the numbers
still delude
themselves it's just you know it's it's
a human trait but you're right the
further you are away from reality which
is the numbers um the further you are
away from
reality so in the book you say quote few
Executives have ever thought of
themselves as a chief profit officer but
that's what the leader needs to be in a
recovering company so the CEO or
executive is the chief profit officer in
a recovering company how's that
different than a normal company or a
growing company should they always be
the chief profit officer or is it
specifically during that recovery period
where it's essential they should always
be the chief profit officer and somebody
should always be I I entered a company
recently the CEO is the on his business
card and and email Chief Visionary the
number two guy was Chief something else
ridiculous and I said listen y'all got
plenty of this Vision stuff and y'all
got plenty of that other stuff uh what
y'all don't have is profits or cash flow
and um and somebody's got to quit that
stupid job that means nothing to me and
become the chief profit officer you know
but I mean you see it who wakes up in
the morning and thinks I got to go shave
some pennies today and I got to go add a
couple basis points to my gross profit
margin every day like they're a monk and
it's the only thing that
matters people just don't do it um and
and and if you don't do that when times
are good um then you're going to end up
where times are bad you know probably
Chances Are Over time and um and it's
just it's like the most fundamental
mindset in the world but we kind of
forget about it and um entrepreneurship
and being executive and all that crap is
so over um
romanticized
um and it has you know and and and the
romance has nothing to do with um
scraping pennies but retiring you know
retiring with a big war chest has
everything to do with scraping
pennies you are probably glamorous of
course you are probably the epitome of a
wartime CEO uh could you be a peacetime
CEO like is it possible for you to run a
business that's not in trouble um
somebody else could I I can't um and um
and I and I think there's a third you
know there's a startup CEO which is a
different breed as well um and usually
when we buy a business I'll run it for
the first 100 days and then and then I
think you need a one-year person that
kind of sets the foundation and really
just starts doing reps and gaining
momentum we're going to do the basics
over and over and over and and then the
third CEO type would be the growth uh
sort of return to normal and growth and
I think they're three completely differ
I can do the first two somebody else
might be able to do the second to but I
can't no I'd be a complete failure as a
peace time
CEO now in Reverse could the peacetime
CEO be the wartime CEO in your
experience occasionally you know these
guys like Bezos or Zuckerberg that can
take it from zero to gazillions I don't
understand how somebody can have both
temperaments um and they're extremely
rare there are people that can do both
the peace time and wartime but um there
I I'm not one of them and and it's
extremely rare bird that can um and I'll
tell you the worst thing in the world is
trying to is fixing a company getting it
right falling not in love but really
believing that you're on the right path
and then the results aren't showing up
and you need to turn it around again
emotionally I have this break where I
just struggle to go in and and take
apart the organization that I just built
over the last two years so I almost need
somebody to come turn around me when I
need to turn around now uh I asked a
friend of mine Lulu m one time about uh
peace time and wartime in Communications
she said something to me that just
seared in my brain which is there is no
difference between peace and wartime it
is pre-war and post-war and maybe that
is what the Mark Zuckerberg's and the
Jeff Bezos right they just they're
prepping for war and then they're kind
of recovering from war and PR pre
prepping for the next one I guess yeah I
I I it astounds me that you know the
same person that can get this this
little idea off the ground you know
anybody who's been through a startup
like it is so hard it's um just to get
momentum and then to be able to do that
and then organ you know organize and
manage a company with aund thousand
employees I it's just two different
universes to me but the the occasional
rare bird can do it there's another line
in the book that uh really resonated
with me which is the bottom line is that
a turnaround will be some formula of
raising prices cutting cost streamlining
operations and fixing bad habits can you
give me an example of each one of these
and maybe we start with raising
prices yeah raising prices
um you know the banal is uh raising
prices the more aggressive is um we've
raised prices on um you know so it's one
thing we're going to raise prices going
forward it's another to say we're
raising prices on our whole backlog that
we haven't even produced yet but we're
just going to add an extra 10% to that
and go tell the customer
the the more extreme version is calling
customers and saying hey and I've done
this hey we're in a bit of a pinch um
two things one we need cash so you've
got to pay us immediately even though
you have 60-day terms that you turn into
75 and the other is we're not profitable
so we're adding 10% to all the open
invoices so um all the invoices you have
ADD 10% to them and pay them today or
we're not shipping any further that goes
over like a lead balloon but you know
you have leverage it works and and you
you know I've saved businesses that way
um it upsets them but a lot of companies
would rather have a viable supplier than
um that than not and if you have that
kind of Leverage you can do it um
cutting cost it what about cutting costs
and what what's maybe the most extreme
situations you've been in there yeah you
know cut well I mean you know it's the
easy ones like you find I remember this
guy was billing 75 hours a week so 35
hours a week in overtime and he had a
20-hour job he was so bored that he
started drinking on a job became an
alcoholic crashed the um the um forklift
still didn't get fired um you know so
you go and like whammo there's there's a
bunch of cost that just got cut um you
know declare uh no more overtime without
approval and everybody fusses I'm like
just come and talk to me I'll approve
sensible overtime um nobody does because
90% of the overtime was BS um
then you know deeper into cost you know
put put your major materials out to bid
most people don't frequently bid their
uh their supply items um and just get
competitive market pressure going and a
lot of it's really Paro analysis you
know we're the 8020 and uh people do a
lot of just you know they're wasting
time on products that don't really work
ideas that don't really work just call
them focus on the on on what delivers
the Bucks and um you know there's your
cost cutting um streamlining operations
again that's pretty much Paro um you
know where are we sitting idle I work on
a lot of manufacturing so it's a lot of
industrial
engineering um you know just work at UH
workflows process scheduling is probably
the single
greatest um place for pickup and profit
it's a you can have people looking super
duper busy and you re-engineer the
scheduling and you can just get out so
much more um
but it's it's scheduling and and and it
makes sense because processes develop
over time um and just become cumbersome
and awkward with lots of bolt-on steps
and whatnot
um scheduling is the best one for that
and then um the bad
habits you know family members soft work
hours soft
expectations um you know are we here to
provide people with a work life balance
or are we here trying to win the
freaking Super Bowl um you know go get a
work life balance somewhere else we're
here to we're here to you know get to
the playoffs and put some wins on the
board and quite frankly keep the
business alive we're not we're not here
for anything else and I I fell into this
early in my career I thought we if we
were more inclusive and we gave people
what they wanted it would work better
and when I rethought it of if I'm Bill
bellich or I'm the general manager of
team and my jobs to win I have no quals
about swapping out my third string
quarterback for a different third string
quarterback but you know when you
personalize and treat everybody as
family it kills you to get rid of a
third string quarterback because you
know maybe had they have some hidden
potential and it that's not my problem
um you know I'm here to staff a team and
and and win um and you just got to bring
in get rid of uh or let me say it this
way you need to upgrade every position
uh
rigorously and consistently and if you
do that you'll have an All-Star team do
you think that it helps that you don't
know the teams before you come in like
absolutely the fact that you're an ex
external person absolutely because I I
would have such a soft heart for so many
people if I if I knew them um without a
doubt and and that's my problem when I'm
running a business after a couple years
that becomes my blond spot you know I
love Bob oh sure he doesn't move that F
but God what a sweet guy and his wife's
got problems I'm such a sucker for all
that I talked to Graham Weaver who runs
Alpine investors they're one of the top
private Equity firms in the world and uh
one of the things Graham told me is 100%
of the time when they buy a business
they switch out the management team and
he said you know sometimes they keep the
manager team sometimes not no one has a
really hard fast rule he goes 100% of
the time we switch him out and one of
the things is uh one you get your people
in there but also two is uh it really
changes the dynamic dnamic of the
business because all of those personal
relationships and you know everyone
knows the person who's the good kind of
smooz right who who's able to get
different things in the business if you
don't have a personal relationship all
of a sudden it comes down to just hey
what what are the rules what are the
ways that we're going to run this
business yeah what what have you what
have youve been accomplishing what you
been doing lately as opposed to 20 years
ago um and and with CTP certified
turnaround professional which is a
designation in our
industry um sacrificial Lambs is part of
the study guide and part of the test and
you have to write about the value of
sacrificial Lambs um as part of the exam
and that is the public display of
somebody getting shikan where and it
tightens everybody else up I had one
situation where U declared an end to um
to um unauthorized
overtime it was a machine shop so guys
ran two machines each one guy refused to
turn his second machine on that day and
said I'm not getting overtime I'm not
turning why would I turn on my second
machine which makes no sense his
supervisor didn't know how to respond to
it so he went to manager manager was
confused by this they came to me I'm in
the office freaked out trying to figure
out how to fund payroll and I don't have
a solution for that and they give me
this Petty thing and I said listen I'm
so busy just bring him in here let me
fire him right in front of everybody
because I don't have I don't have time I
don't have more than 30 seconds to fire
this clown um and they said okay and
they went out and said listen you're not
turning your machine Sans wants you to
come in there so he can fire you in
front of everybody in the office and he
said I think I'll just turn my second
machine
on and that was it but you know the word
shot through the whole Factory and and
everybody realize I'm serious and I
don't play those games and we're here to
win and um and you know it's nice to get
a sacrificial lamb without actually
having to throw somebody out the door
yeah you got to change you got to change
that thinking you can't you can't soft
pedal change as we have seen uh over the
last two years or so tech companies
especially early stage uh kind of
venture backed companies have struggled
quite uh mightily is this turnaround
Playbook can it be used in the tech
sector as much as in a lot of the
manufacturing or industrial engineering
businesses you're talking about I I
would say absolutely because um you know
ultimately it's about uh cost versus uh
revenues and um but you got to have
product Market fit I get Tech compan
coming to me that haven't achieved
product Market fit and you know what do
I do it's like you're a drift in in in
the ocean and you've never seen land and
you want me to navigate you towards land
like I have no idea what to do but if I
can go into a company that like well we
were profitable we now we're not fine I
just reverse engineer like okay what
changed how do we get back to where
we're
profitable that's pretty easy but you
know people that have never been I I
don't know how to make them suddenly and
then real quickly Tech also you know
you've got your in there's generally two
turnarounds income statement turnaround
which is your profitability and balance
sheet turnaround so you maybe you're
profitable but your debts are killing
you um Tech has a somewhat different
debt stack as well so that's got to be
treated differently but you know on the
surface it's um if gross margins are
greater than expenses uh you're you're
profitable and if not get them there so
debt I think is a really interesting
thing where most of the physical economy
runs on debt of some form or fashion uh
in the tech world most people are only
familiar with either convertable debt
which really they just treat as an
equity investment that yet hasn't been
kind of finalized or Venture debt um
talk your perspective on debt and and
you know maybe what some of the Hang-Ups
are and then also times where you've
seen it work really really well this
episode has brought to you by frck
historically the wealthy had a hidden
secret in investing they would spend a
lot of money and use very three big
teams to conduct tax loss harvesting tax
loss harvesting is the timely selling of
Securities at a loss to offset the
amount of capital gains tax owed from
selling the profitable assets later but
now frk is bringing this incredible
advantage to any investor they'll
literally lower your tax bill regardless
of how much money you have they use
state-of-the-art technology through a
product called direct indexing to allow
investors to invest in the S&P 500 while
getting all the benefits of tax loss
harvesting without the big Bill if you
want to learn more go check them out at
fre.com that's
fc.com I'm a big fan of the product and
I even became an investor in the
business fre.com go check them out today
the I I often say that this sounds
ironic but Bank debt is is one of the
best things you can have is because it
it it the discipline and rigor of
dealing with Bank debt is so great that
it keeps you focused and keeps you
online and I see we worked on a company
this year who was trying to
revolutionize some Building Product they
burned up $50 million accomplished
nothing um you can't do that with Bank
debt you can do it with friends and
family you can do it with Equity but you
can't burn up that kind of money on a
frivolous adventure with uh with bank
Deb and um that's what I kind of like
about Bank Deb the the rigor and
discipline keeps you from screwing up to
that extent one of my mentors has like
80 companies every single one of them
does a daily borrowing base certificate
where they you know if you're an
asset-based lending even even folks
without debt even companies are
incredibly profitable every single day
they do a daily borrowing base
certificate what's the value of my
receivables what's the value of my
inventory how much can I borrow against
that what's my cash position how much
Headroom do I have on
cash um and that's just if you watch
that you're not going to get in trouble
or you're going to see trouble coming
you know months in advance you're not
going to be surprised by it same with
the 13we uh cash flow forecast which is
somewhat similar which works in tech
companies or you know even asset light
um you know we do 13we cash flows weekly
for all of our companies and um are
always trying to see around the Horizon
uh or Over the Horizon you know what
could be coming what what's a downturn
and um and how could we how could we get
in trouble that we don't see it and that
but family and friends will never make
you do that uh investors will never make
you do that and um that's why a lot of
tech companies just uh flame out um you
know the the flip side is they're not
going to get Bank debt because they
don't have assets and they don't have
collateral um and you know you can't
borrow from a bank if you don't have
either collateral or a hell of a um
proven earnings history and which
obviously you know a tech startup
doesn't so I'm going in a circle here so
they have to go to equity but you and
friends and family but you know equity
and friends and family should be running
a tighter ship um but they don't and um
I think I don't know that's what I like
about uh that's what I love about
manufacturing it's also tangible it's
real and
um and and it's if you do it right it's
um it's hard to hard to lose your mind
along the way you mentioned a mentor uh
most people would say that you're one of
the best if not the best in the business
what have you learned from your mentor
oh my God all my mentors um yeah
everything I I learned I learned a
turnaround game from a mentor I learned
the um distress investing game for a
mentor and um I never purposely sought
out mentors but um but I've seem to have
always throughout my life had them
picked them up along the way um I can't
say you know when I was in high school I
wanted to um I wanted to be a
professional football player and we
lived outside New Orleans and some of
the saints were moving to our
neighborhood I went and took took over
every single lawn contract of every
single player in my town and they all
said I got somebody doing my lawn I'm
like you didn't understand me I'm taking
over your lawn contract if it's price
I'll beat them on price if it's service
I'll beat him on service but Jeff Sans
is gonna cut Kenny saber's grass and I'm
not leaving um and it was awesome and
then you know then they all became my
buddies and I got to spend the summer at
uh in Vero Beach at summer camp and fly
around on the playing the best thing in
the world and I kind of did that when I
took a fancy to turnarounds I found the
best guy I could find and wouldn't
wouldn't leave him alone until he
basically adopted me um and then same
with distressed investing I wouldn't
leave him alone I just kept bringing him
deals and then um and then we started
doing them together that's there's best
career path you can pick talk about the
difference between turnarounds and
distressed investing because they're
related and they're somewhat sequential
but some people choose just to do
distress investing and some people want
to just be in the turnaround game and so
why do you think that there's advantages
uh or opportunity in being you know
somewhat um ad advantageous or expert at
both of those
things um well I I think there's
distressed investors who don't really do
turnarounds because they're Financial
they can run the numbers they can do all
the
modeling they can talk about it but they
don't know how to go on the Factory 4
and motivate people um there's people
who can go on the Factory 4 and motiv
folks who just don't understand leverage
finance and some of these other things
uh you know and how to successfully pull
off a
deal uh you know if you can do both then
you're um you know if you can if you can
buy the take buy or take over the
problem and then actually go fix it um I
don't you know if you're a control freak
like me that's great because you can you
can see the whole problem and the
solution and um you don't have to depend
on anybody else to get you there you
know other than like your you know your
trusted
teammates now um another part of this
that seems really interesting is uh
labor every single time I talk to anyone
in the fysical economy they tell me
Labor's a problem it's a restaurant it's
manufacturing whatever uh you have the
uh blessing of having to recruit labor
to a crisis situation it's one thing
when you're the turnaround guy you're
the guy who's used to doing this you're
choosing to go do this but now you have
to convince people to come work at a
business that's basically failing how do
you do that how much of it is like you
just tell them it's failing you try to
motivate them to come and help versus
you got to show kind of the shiny you
know uh kind of rose-colored glasses and
and sell them the dream how how do you
recruit people to these crisis
situations uh largely selling the dream
um you know often I often I go in and uh
I remember one everybody's like boy of
Rick were're here you should bring back
Rick um boy of Rick were're here and I'm
like who's Rick so I went on oh my God I
got a bunch of stories like that where
you just hear his name and then you go
find a guy like everybody wants want you
back they all thought you were the best
here's what we're doing with the
business here's your role you can be the
hero of this journey um and what else
you doing you know you're your boss
doesn't care about you you're stuck
we're we're going to love you and
worship you you got to come back others
I just recruited in a um controller for
a uh distress company that we don't have
a solution for she can see the numbers
right there but you know the pitch is um
you know you're going to learn all about
turnarounds it's going to be fun um it's
going to be a hell of a roing adventure
if it doesn't work um you know go back
and get a boring job uh but you know if
it if it does work hey it works and you
got this fantastic education and great
experience and I'll give you a heck of a
reference and it's a th% sale job you
know I'm just you're right I don't have
much to work with but I'm I'm shining it
up as best as I possibly can that makes
complete sense um in the chapter called
building long-term value you say there's
four things that can be done immediately
for a business uh one is get rid of the
turnaround
consultant explain that like most people
would say wait why is this guy saying
get rid of the turnaround a consultant
yeah well you know once the uh the
business is profitable the balance
sheets cleaned up I um I'm just taking
up space I'm billing a lot and I'm not
providing much value anymore and it's
just it's time for me to move on um some
turn Consultants will not have the next
thing lined up so they'll try to stay
there but it it's just time to get rid
of them get rid of that expense and move
on
um yeah sorry that was answering your
question the second one is maintain a
monastic focus on the fundamentals of
running a lean and profitable company
and that seems like maybe just like
reinforce the good habits yeah yeah
basically you know the it's Paro but
it's just that that focus and I I don't
know how can you be successful at
anything without a monastic monk-like
focus on the fundamentals and if you do
that you're going to stay out of trouble
uh and and probably the reason you end
up in the turnaround is you didn't do
that you got distracted by other stuff
by chasing um shiny
objects but if you just do the right
things over and over and over and keep
your life simple you should probably
avoid trouble number three and four is
gain core strength and accumulate
resources and then pick the right
strategic Direction that you're lean and
flexible and it seems like rather than
try to um you know improve your
weaknesses to some degree you're saying
hey lean into the strengths and really
kind of accumulate those resources
explain that further yeah it it really
is which probably goes back to the Paro
you know what are we going to be
exceptional about really clean up and
focused and um you know uh book profits
and just put them into retain earnings
and strengthen your balance sheet don't
go chasing shiny objects don't go try to
create a new division just do your thing
and do it well and get strong get your
feet super strong underneath you um and
then when it is time to go expand you
know do that with just laser like
intensity and don't don't loose don't
lose your focus your foundation your
laser like intensity because everything
other than that is just risk and it's a
it's a tough world out there um and
there's just bad you know you like
remember successories posters they'd say
dumb like um you know there's no
such thing about luck it's just about
preparation and every life coach who
says there's no such thing as luck or
whatever they all buy insurance because
there's bad luck there's good luck and
bad luck and um you know bad luck's out
there and it doesn't matter nothing else
matters you get I mean I got I lost a
factory to a I lost a factory in a home
to a hurricane what the hell could I
have done to prepare for that um it just
you know bad luck's going to happen
there's fires there's uh
tornadoes and if you don't have a strong
core it it it it can be fatal if you
have a really strong core you can
probably weathered storm let's talk
about liquidating a business or
liquidating assets uh in these crisis
situations you need cash you need it
quickly and so selling some of the
assets potentially could help you do
that but a lot of times especially if
you're selling a a business unit or or
something that isn't just a physical
asset uh could take a long time even a
real estate deal could take a long time
and so how have you in your career
expedited these sales and really ensure
that you get the cash as quickly as
possible um you're you're right that it
can take time and um the more of a hurry
you're in the lower the price you're
going to get you know for a piece of
equipment or real estate it's more than
anything um if you think of yourself and
then you think of all your stakeholders
your customers your vendors your lender
everybody else they all have balance
sheets what you're trying to do is pull
cash off of their balance sheets onto
yours um and then uh and and then at
some point you you you push the the cash
back onto theirs as you get through this
hole you know if I got a piece of real
estate or equipment I can um I can sell
an option in it I can sell a part of it
I can borrow against it I can take a
hard money loan against it while I'm
going for a sale um maybe I can get the
bank to advance me a little bit more if
we have the real estate
listed it's how do I get cash from other
people's pockets into mine so I can I I
I can you know pay great working capital
pay for my expenses keep keep my
employees going buy materials and spin
that and then ultimately generate
profits and then be able to push that
back out and most people if you say hey
I'm just going to borrow from you for a
little while and then I'm going to give
it back but I've got a bombproof plan
we're going to track it every day I'll
be 100%
transparent they they'll buy into it um
you know because they want a customer
they want a vendor um and I always you
know if you got a good plan people
support it if you got
a if you don't have a good plan people
aren't going to support that either and
and the world's just full of plans that
aren't that great when you go in uh how
much of it is you come up with a plan
yourself and then you approve the plan
yourself and you go implement the plan
versus you're looking for kind of
consensus right whether it is with uh
investors whether it's maybe some people
at the business how do you just think
about you know setting the plan and then
actually approving that plan
um the it's a great question um the you
know I walk in as baguer as the
entrepreneur is I mean some there's just
some bad CEOs but usually I say you're
still the most qualified person in the
world to run this business you don't
feel like it you've really had your head
kicked in um but you're the single most
qualified person to run this business
today and then I get them to give me the
ideas how do we get out of this
situation if they can't come up with
that with that or you know so often I'll
take their disjointed ideas and put into
a plan if they don't even have
disjointed ideas then I basically come
up with a plan myself um there's no
consensus there's uh absolute
buyin um I don't need everybody to think
it's a swell plan I need everybody to
get behind it and execute on the plan
whether they like it or not and
everybody's free to leave and sometimes
people have to leave
but it's it's about the execution and
you know if you leave it up to the
inmates to come up with a plan and
execute it I mean there's a reason I got
called in the first place um and it's
not because y'all were doing a great
job when you think about um maybe
external pressure another thing that's
really interesting is uh in these let's
say a local Town people know that there
is a crisis happening and so whether it
is kind of the whisper Network and and
you know people go to the bar at night
and they're talking about it or or maybe
even local papers writing about the
problems Etc that kind of compounds some
of these issues how do you deal with
maybe the soft stuff right it's not
numbers it's not you know the actual
business itself but you're trying to
almost manage expectations or or maybe
change the narrative around a business
in the local
community it it's really hard um and as
you can imagine entrepreneurs
personalize their business it it's it's
part of them um you know I get some that
won't won't cut the country club
membership because they're afraid of how
it'll look and I get on the other side I
get people who just bravely go into
bankruptcy will call the paper and say
hey we're going to file it's going to be
news I want you to have the inside scoop
and this is what we're doing and this is
why we're doing it they'll go to the
trade show and deal with all the vendors
who haven't been paid and um it's I I
have one of those now but it's rare to
have somebody with that sort of Courage
the employees is tough and the toughest
part of the employees like I can talk
talk to people all day long and you know
pump them up and tell them it's going to
be okay and here's their plan all that
stuff and they go home and their spouse
starts nibbling at them or their jerk
brother-in-law starts nibbering at them
like oh blah blah blah that's really
hard to overcome and you know Monday
everybody needs to be built back up and
you lose some in the process but yeah
you're totally right that how it plays
out in public is um fragile is probably
the best word for it last question I
have for you is
uh in the book there is a quote uh and I
think it's in the beginning of the book
it says despite being impatient and
Relentless Jeff is the happiest guy on
Earth and there's some sort of uh
dichotomy almost of like you're running
into the fire every single day you're
just seeing absolute you know uh uh
everything in shambles businesses are
failing people are stressed uh there's
all kinds of uncomfortable tough
situations or conversations yet you
remain really happy how do you do
that number one not my neck into the
Noose um and when it was my first two
turnarounds were in my own business and
you know I was looking at losing my home
um that wasn't
fun but I love untangling big complex
problems that other people can untangle
and um the ability to do that and have
all this action and not risk losing my
home is I think it's just the coolest
thing in the world um and I often say I
you know I hope on my dying day on my
deathbed somebody calls me to talk about
deal structure because i' I'd love to
love to have one more one more
conversation on buying a distressed
asset uh before I check out I love
it so Jeff you wrote the book corporate
turn around Artistry fix any business in
100 days I highly suggest people if you
have not read this yet please go pick it
up and read it it's fantastic book and
and I think part of what makes it so
good it's very practical obviously but
um it's also uh looking at these
turnaround situations and it really can
reinforce and teach good habits and and
things that you should be doing with the
healthy business as well so it's it's
focused on turnarounds but it's really
about how do you run a business
correctly and avoid these mistakes um
I've learned a lot today uh I appreciate
your time where can we send people to
find you or uh if somebody unfortunately
has a turnaround situation and needs
your help where where can I get in touch
with you um so my website is Dorset
partners.com
doct partners.com uh you can find me
there Jeff dors Partners my email I'm on
LinkedIn and um Twitter and stuff like
that um but yeah and you know again my
dying day um I love these conversations
I love getting phone calls and um yeah I
I get such a kick out of this it's I
it's not work for
me I love to hear that all right Jeff
thank you so much for doing this we'll
definitely do it again in the future
thank you Anthony it's been a blast take
care